now back in july a statistical anomaly
was spotted which changed the way that
deaths from covert 19 accounted
previously public health england
included any death of a person who had
once had covert 19
as a coronavirus fatality even if they'd
recovered from the virus
and died of another cause now the man
who spotted that was professor carl
hennigan from the
university of oxford someone who has
been quite critical of the uk's decision
to lock down he joins us now
i'm not sure if you managed to catch any
of my interview with matt hancock but he
was effectively saying that he can't
rule out
further national restrictions if people
don't
do things like obey the rule of six and
if cases continue to rise
do you think the government will be
right to tighten the rules further
well look this is a time to now just be
calm and cool
and particularly analytical at what's
happening
what we're seeing is that the virus is
operating in a seasonal way
as we've gone back to schools actually
what's happened now is we've seen about
a 60
increase in consultations for all acute
respiratory infections
and that's what's driving the problems
in the test and trace program
all the young children who have coughs
and colds and these infections
one of them is an infection called
rhinovirus in fact as we look at the
data
covert is operating in a similar
seasonal way
and mirroring that respiratory
infections so what we have to do now is
slow down
this is a long winter we cannot afford
to go now with harsh measures
because as len just said the impact on
the economy here is going to be
significant
because what happens is soon as you
pause then you open up again
it tends to come back the problem for
the government
is what we can't afford to do is people
to become complacent
so we still have to be vigilant about
ensuring
the infections stay manageable across
the board
some would say though that it's better
to act early
so we don't have to lock down too
stringently in the future so
if you like the idea is that as the
cases start to tick up there's
concerns that it could lead to
exponential growth the r rate is
increasing and so actually acting early
would mean that we wouldn't have to
have the heavy fist of another national
lockdown in the future
look i think that underpins a
fundamental misunderstanding of what
happens with community
pathogens whatever you do if you lock
down now you slow down the progression
slightly
but then you'll get a resurgence because
what happens is in in the population is
there has to be a level of immunity
for this to become manageable so a very
good example of this will be older
if you go and look at oldham data today
on august the second they had a
resurgence of cases
came in hard restrictive measures more
testing tracing
but actually in the last week now they
now have the highest case numbers
they've had it in the last eight weeks
so this is the problem what we do need
to do is create a test and trace system
that's highly effective let that work
and what you're seeing amongst the
population is a single message that is
now missing
is if you have symptoms you have to
isolate
and i'm picking up a lot of people who
just do not understand that
because we haven't been clear about that
messaging and this is incredibly
important
it's become so confusing people think if
you've got the rule of six
they can go about even if they've got
symptoms so we need to clarify
and make the messaging very simple for
the population
and if we do that we can go through the
winter highly vigilant
and not need lockdown um you it's
interesting they talk about the
messaging and some of the confusion
around it
in the mail on sunday today you've said
that the prime minister is surrounded by
mediocre scientific advisors what do you
mean by that what mistakes are they
making
well one of the problems here is this is
a
pathogen that affects healthcare it is
directly
impacting on public health doctors who
are at the front line trying to manage
this
i speak to them on a daily basis get
emails clinicians like primary care
doctors who
manage respiratory infections all the
time one of the bits that's missing
in the architecture is all of them
people input into the advice system
there are too many non-clinical people
focusing on a single disease
covid the second issue every time you
decide to lock down
you should have competing models that
say what's the impact now going to be on
other diseases
because it is huge every time you do
that so this has to go in the mix now
when you make decisions that's why we're
saying slow down
get a wider range of expertise in the
room
so you can make a much more balanced
decision about what you're going to
actually do
and its impact not just on covid what
about all the other infections what
about all the cancers the heart disease
all of these other issues and then your
educational
and then your social situation and the
economy they all have to go now
into the mix of the decision are you
worried that the negative
impact of lockdown and also further
restrictions as you just outlined
could actually outweigh the negative
impact of the virus itself
i'm going to tell you what i think right
now if we go now it's too early
we have to understand the context of
respiratory infections
between now and christmas and about
january consultations will go up
fourfold
for respiratory infections in primary
care that's in a good year
in a bad year they'll go up eightfold
everybody in the background with
children will recognize this
as it gets colder as we're inside more
there'll be more coughs and cold
therefore there may come a point in the
winter when actually there's a need for
restrictive measures if i was talking
about what the prime minister's talking
about a cycle break
i'd be looking at the christmas break
right now to extend it
and i can tell you why that's the case
because often when we come back in
january there's a significant rise in
deaths in the month of january
about 5000 per week more than what we
see
right now and that's due to the seasonal
effects
therefore if you're looking at a break
and when we need it we need it in the
mid-winter
when we might run into problems but
actually it would be more explainable to
people why we're doing it then
than now there's no evidence right now
of what's called a second wave
because that's about the prime
minister's wrong then
well look what we've got to do is what's
difficult here
is i get for our ministers this is an
incredibly complicated area
some of the issues we're talking about
require five six years of healthcare
experience to really get your head
around
so this is about good advice to the
prime minister
to the health secretary that allows a
wider range of expertise to come on
board
and if they did that they might look at
the problem slightly different
what they do have a problem though as
i've said is can't afford the population
to become complacent
so i think over the next few weeks if we
can see a more slower analytical
approach to the data
and a different approach to the advice
the prime minister
might see a subtle change in his
language that reflects a need to
normalize what's going on this is a
seasonal effect now
and if it becomes worse and it becomes
impacted on disease
then yes that's the point when we ask
for restrictive measures
but that is not time is not now now
you've said previously that we need to
have a rational debate
about when it is better to get this
infection
do you think there's an argument then
that we should be relaxed about or even
encourage
people under the age of 45 getting
coronavirus
well what there's been a tendency under
the government is to focus on the worst
case scenario country so they looked to
spain
and said look here's where we're heading
but you could look to
two other countries you could look to
sweden who've had this rational debate
now remember sweden didn't do nothing
they
managed they controlled the disease so
they're in the population it was at
manageable levels
so through the summer they had much
higher cases than we had
when the impact of the disease is low
and actually its impact on healthcare
services is much lower
that's creating population immunity the
only other way to do that is through
vaccination
and it's looking like the vaccination is
not going to be available until the end
of the winter
and even if we do have a vaccination
that we need to forget
some level of population immunity which
is what we do for all other infections
in the community
that's at the same time though at the
same time though the recent studies seem
to suggest that our immunity levels are
pretty low perhaps as you say because we
haven't followed
the model like sweden and obviously this
is a very
deadly disease for older people
vulnerable people
are we really saying that you're asking
people to shield indefinitely what do
they have to go to work are you saying
that they're not allowed to see their
grandchildren
i mean what kind of life is that now
look for instance if you look at germany
germany is a very good example
one of the issues in germany is the over
75 case fatality rate is the same across
europe completely the same it's not like
their health care improves their
outcomes
but what they did is have a strategy to
reduce the number of infections in over
75 year olds
where over 75 of the deaths occur so if
you understand that basic principle
yes right now there is a signal in care
homes
that we need a care on control plan as a
matter of urgency to shield that
population
if you do that well you'll get rid of 40
percent of the mortality
if you improve nosocomial infections
hospital acquired infections
you may get rid of another 10 or 20 well
there you've got
sixty percent of the problem because
this affects the most vulnerable the
most
frail which most respiratory pathogens
do
now if we don't accept that the disease
is endemic and out there
and have control plans what we're doing
is misguided
and not putting our attention where it's
required
it's required in reducing the infection
in the most vulnerable
in the most frail very interesting
perspective
indeed carl hennigan thank you so much
for being on the show today thank you